Green: Hi, everybody.
I'm Travis Green, product
manager on the Prediction API.
We're here to talk to you today
about smart application design,
uh, but first, I want to do
a little survey of the audience.
So how many of you have ever
built or wanted to build
a recommendation system
for one of your applications?
Not bad. Okay.
I got a hand wave up here.
[laughs]
Uh, how many of you
have ever wanted to do
a sentiment analysis
on one of your app--
in one of your applications?
Okay.
How many of you have ever had to
do something really repetitive
to make one of
your applications work?
Okay.
So we're here today
to talk to you about
how you can stop doing some
of those more repetitive things.
Um--oop--
there we go.
So first, we should think about,
what is a smart application?
Um, the screen here shows you
three themes that we talk about,
and some examples
of smart applications.
I'm gonna walk through
each of them.
Then we'll move into, um,
talking about how all these
sorts of things work,
then we'll show off how
the Prediction API works.
Um, my colleagues Max and Robert
will give a demo of--
live coding demo
of how the system
can be built from scratch.
And then Johannes
and Ryan over there from Ford
will talk about how
they've been using the API,
and then we'll talk about
some of the really cool things
that we announced yesterday,
and show them off to you.
So first, what is
a smart application?
Um, we think about
smart applications with--
at the Prediction API team
as things that automate
the repetitive,
extract the essential,
and recommend the useful.
So things that automate
the repetitive
are things like
content moderation.
So let's imagine
you're running a blog,
and you have a forum
on that blog,
and you get a lot of spam,
you know, say, spam about, um,
certain drugs you don't
want to see on your blog.
Filtering those out
is really frustrating
and really complicated, um,
because sometimes the patterns
that you'll be seeing
from that spam will change.
And so with the Prediction API,
you can go and you can say,
"Well, I have all this data
that I've used in the past,
"so I have labeled
all these comments
"as things that
should be posted
"or things that
shouldn't be posted,
"and I can take those lessons
and apply them
to new comments coming in."
So I can say,
"All right, well, these,
"the ones that score very high,
are automatically posted.
"The ones that scores--
that score very low
"are automatically rejected,
and the small group
in the middle,
I will look at myself."
So something that--
now moving on to things
that extract the essential--
a great example of this
is GMAIL'S priority inbox.
It takes the patterns
that you have shown
by looking at messages
over time,
and then applies those patterns
to incoming messages,
so that you know--
you can see the most important
ones right at the top.
Now things that recommend
the useful.
The example onscreen is, um,
an apps recommender
written by one of the developer
relations people here at Google,
that takes
certain characteristics
about a business, you fill out
these five questions,
and then it
predicts applications
you're most likely
to be interested in.
That's a very simple form,
but you can imagine things
getting much more complicated.
Um, some of the more
complicated things
would be things like Pandora,
which gives you an infinite
stream of music
from pieces of music
people have liked,
and also things that--
the intrinsic characteristics
of the music itself.
Another example--
this team's from New York,
so we always are trying to get
cabs late at night,
and one of the great
applications in New York
is called CabSense,
which, you know,
depending on where
you're standing in the city,
will look at all of
the cab rides, uh, for years,
millions of cab rides,
and tell you which corner
to stand on
to catch a cab most quickly.
So you can think about
these sorts of applications
as being the forefront of a new
generation of applications.
But we're left
with the question of,
how do you
build these things?
You know, um, they may seem
like magic on the front,
but there's gotta be
something behind them.
So machine learning
is a great way to do this.
Um, It's something
that many people seem to think
you need a PhD in statistics,
or a PhD in complex
mathematics to do.
But we make it really easy.
So the screen here shows you
just conceptually
how all that works.
You take a set of inputs,
a set of examples,
look at them, see how, um--
see what things have indicated,
a certain kind of behavior,
learn patterns
and create
a model of that input set,
and then use that when you have
a new example coming in
to predict characteristics
about it as an output.
So now this slide shows you
how the Prediction API
makes that really easy.
Um, we talk about three
simple HTTP calls,
the first being that you want
to upload a predictive mo--
or, upload data for your
predictive model to learn from.
Then you say to the API,
"Well, I want to train
a predictive model
from my data," so then we
go out and we apply
many different algorithms to try
to find the best possible one.
Then when you have
a new example come in,
say, a new piece of text you
want to know the sentiment of,
of a new user who you want
to recommend, uh,
different content to,
the system will then apply
the lessons its learned,
the patterns its learned,
to that new example,
and show you an output
that indicates, you know,
what sorts of content
that user is interested in,
or what the sentiment
of that specific post is.
Now this system was available
to preview developers
before yesterday,
so we're very,
very happy to announce
that all of you here
and everyone across the world
can try it out.
Uh, we are both offering
a free quota
for anyone to try out
the system,
and then also an SLA
for users who want to make
bigger applications,
um, and that
will be a paid tier,
so you can see that we have
a 3 9's service level agreement.
That is to ensure
that you guys
can be sure you
can depend on us,
that the system will always
be there when you need it.
[applause]
Green: Um, thank you.
I'd like to now turn it over
to Max and Robert,
who will show you
with some live code,
how you build one of these
applications yourself.
Lin: Hi, everyone.
My name's Max Lin.
Uh, I'm a server engineer
on the Prediction API team.
Uh, this is
my colleague Robert.
Um, so as Travis said,
today at the I/O,
we are going to make
this Prediction API
generally available,
so what does that mean to you?
That means everyone
that is in this room,
and also the people seeing this
presentation through the video,
you can sign up right now
and use the Prediction API
to make your, uh, apps smarter.
So let me show you how you--
how easy you can sign out
the Prediction API now.
So we are going to use a tool
called Google APIs console,
so in case you haven't noticed,
this is a new, uh,
like, a one-stop place for you
to use various Google APIs.
So here, I'm going
to show you, um,
you can go
to Google APIs console,
or go to the URL
on the screen.
It's
code.google.com/apis/console.
And so let me just show you
how you can sign out
Prediction API.
So for the first time,
you go to APIs console.
On the screen,
you will see a list of APIs,
and Google Prediction API
is one of them.
So how do you sign up?
How do you, uh,
and sign-up is pretty easy.
It's just one
simple mouse click,
and if you go to Prediction API,
yeah, and click,
and that come up,
and then you can start to use
Prediction API.
Just one simple mouse click,
you can use.
Uh, on the top, you will see
a yellow bar.
It kind of reminds you
to sign up
Google Storage for Developers.
Uh, I'm going to explain to you
why you need to sign up this.
Uh, in a very simple sense,
Prediction API is all about
learning from historical data,
and how do you pass
the historical data
to Google Prediction API?
You upload the data
to Google storage.
Uh, Google storage
is a storage service
running on a cloud,
and again,
it's very easy to sign up
Google storage for developers.
Uh, if you scroll down,
you will see storage--
that is there,
and you just, again,
single mouse click,
and you can sign up
Google storage, too.
And that's it.
Um, and we already signed up
the Prediction API,
and we are ready
to start use.
So for the following
presentation, um,
I'm going to run--
give you running examples
of monitoring such a media.
So suppose you are a company,
and you are interested in, uh,
various social media,
and you are interested--
like, for me,
I like, uh, three topics.
So whenever people mention
App Engine, Android, or Chrome,
I want to automatically
detect that,
and try to kind of
give me alert.
So how do you do that?
So you can, he mentioned,
you have some input,
and you want to generate
some output.
And input here
will be a piece of text.
So it's a piece of text
you find on a social media.
And what's the output we want?
We want to automatically detect
this is--
that this piece of text
is about App Engine,
Android, or Chrome.
That's what we want.
We want some output
in three categories.
So how do you do that?
So imagine you sit down,
you want to write this function,
a very simple input and output
mapping yourself,
which is pretty hard,
because it's hard
to figure out the rules.
The rules can be complex.
So I'm going to show you how you
can use Prediction API,
uh, to learn the mappings,
um, using machine learning
technologies
we use internally at Google,
and we open it up, and it's
a Prediction API for you to use,
and hopefully then,
you can leverage this
Prediction API
to make your apps smarter.
So the first step
is called "upload,"
and this basically
boils down to
collect a bunch of examples.
And those examples
I show on the screen--
Uh, in a minute,
you will see two lines
in a very simple, common,
separated value format,
and one example per line,
and the first line,
you will see the first
column is, uh, #appengine.
In the second column
is a piece of text,
the python library, uh,
for hosted SQL.
So one example per line,
and you collect
as many examples as you can.
So what do we want to do
with this?
We basically collect
historical data,
how people talk about
App Engine, Android, or Chrome.
We collect as many examples
as we can.
Um, so you put these examples
as a file,
so you see here,
we save this one examples,
two examples,
and many, many examples,
in a file,
in this very simple CSV format.
And to, uh,
how do we pass this file
to Google storage?
Uh, we are going to show you,
using a very simple tool
called GSUtil.
And this tool, it's just
one of the many tools
you can upload file
to Google storage.
And I'm gonna show--
this is a common line tool
called GSUtil,
and, uh, we do "cp."
I'm going to copy
the training file
"my_data,"
and this file consists
of many, many lines
of the social media tags
talking about App Engine,
Android, or Chrome,
that we already know for sure.
Then we upload
to Google storage,
and the syntax is gs://io11,
and io11 is just a bucket, uh,
it's the way how Google storage
organize your files.
And inside this bucket,
we are going to call this file
/my_data,
and that's it.
So let's, uh, run it.
And so what happened
behind the scene here, you see,
is the file, the historical data
about the social media,
uh, actually copied
from this ledger
to the Google storage
in the cloud now.
And that's it. That's
just a simple first step.
You collect a bunch of data,
you collect historical data,
you upload to Google storage.
So let's look
at the second step.
It's called "training."
And in this step, we want
to tell Prediction API,
"Hey, go over
my historical data,
"learn the mappings
between inputs and outputs."
And though it may sound simple,
but behind the scenes,
we do a very--
uh, various optimizations
and use the technology
we use internally at Google.
We run that
and run many, many different
machinery algorithms
and pick the one that's best
for your own data.
And so how do you interact
with Prediction API?
So in the middle, you will see,
um, it's a simple HTTP call.
So Prediction API--
it's a RESTful service.
And the way you interact
with Prediction API
is through the network,
through the HTTP protocol.
So here, in order to ask
for Prediction API
to start training,
you make a POST call.
And the URL is pretty simple.
It's just
prediction/v1.2/training.
Inside the body
of this HTTP POST call
you specify the name
you just uploaded
to Google storage.
And that's it.
You just tell
Google Prediction API,
um, to start a training job
and look over
this historical data
that you specify in the body
of the HTTP call.
And the training
is running asynchronously.
So when you make a call
and training starts--
and it depends on the size.
It can take a while.
So how do you know
the training is finished?
Uh, in order to know
the training is finished or not,
you'd make another GET call,
and the syntax is very similar.
It's the URL.
And instead of POST call,
you make a GET call.
So let me show you, uh,
how we can actually do
the training right now,
uh, using a tool
called, uh,
Google APIs Explorer.
So just in case, uh,
you haven't seen this,
it's a web app
for you to explore
various Google APIs.
So Google Prediction API
is one of them.
So when you, uh--
uh, the APIs for--
um, on the le--
first column you will see
a bunch
of different Google APIs.
So you click "Prediction API."
Uh, right now,
our version is v1.2.
That will show
in the second column.
And the third column is
the various methods
Google Prediction API provides.
So every URL is one method.
You can try them out.
So if you want to try that out--
say we want to make
a training call.
Let's try
the training.insert.
So you click "training.insert,"
and we can--
you can start to, uh,
fill the body.
So here, we want to make
a training call
against the file
of historical data
we just upload to.
So we're inside the body.
We open up this text box,
and we type the input
in JSON format.
And there's only one field
you have to provide.
It's the name
of the historical data
you uploaded to Google storage.
So here is io11/my_data,
and that's the name
we want Prediction API
to look at.
That's it.
So that's just, uh,
making this call right now
from the Google APIs Explorer.
And the path that you would
see this as a response--
returned by Prediction API.
Again, on the top request,
you will see
it's a simple POST call
to the, uh, URL
you see on the screen.
In the path
in the response section,
you will see that's a response
returned by Prediction API
over the network
through the APIs Explorer.
So the response--
uh, the first you see
is "200 OK."
That's HTTP status code,
so that means our call
is successful.
And the path that you
will see the response body--
it's JSON.
And you will see, um,
returner kind
and what's the I.D.
And everything looks fine,
so that means our training
already starts
and starts in the background
running in the cloud.
And Prediciton API
starts to parse
your historical data,
running multiple,
different machinery algorithms
and try to learn
the relationship
in your data.
And that's it.
You finished the second step,
the training step.
Now let's look
at the third step,
uh, called "predict."
and this is probably the...
This is probably
the most frequent step
you are going to do in, um,
in your--
in your applications.
In this step, you--
you get a new piece of text,
a new piece of input,
and you don't know the category.
And in our case, we don't know--
we want to predict--
we want to identify this
as our App Engine,
Android, or Chrome?
So we want to make a prediction
against this new piece of text.
So again, um, in this--
the URL--
the syntax is similar,
and it's still one URL
you have to call.
And you have to specify the name
after the--
so if you read the--
the call is
POST prediction/v1.2/
training/io11--
uh, my_data.
And that's the--
again, it's the same file name
you upload to Google storage.
After that, you append
the predict.
That means you want
to make a prediction
against that particular set
of historical data.
So inside the body, we specify
the new piece of text
we want to make a prediction.
So here, uh, the body again--
it's in simple JSON format.
And you have
to only specify, um,
the new piece of text
in a field called, um...
The I.D. is, uh--
this is called csvInstance.
CSV stands for
comma-separated values instance.
And inside that field,
you populate
the piece of text
you want to send over
to Prediction API
over the network.
So here, we just, uh,
have an example.
"What's a smart Android app?"
So that's a new piece of text.
You don't know
what they're talking about.
But you want Prediction API,
based on your historical data,
and make a prediction,
and return what's
the most likely hashtag
or category it's about.
Um, and here,
I-I give you example
of a categorization,
and Prediction API
also supports regression.
And by "regression," we mean if
you want to predict something,
it's real values.
So here for classification,
it's all discrete categories--
App Engine or Android or Chrome.
But for regression problems,
you want to predict something
with real values,
like given
the people's height,
you want to predict
their weight.
And weight is not discrete.
Weight is continuous numbers.
And Prediction API
also supports that.
Um, so I'm going to show
how we're going to make
a Prediction API call--
a prediction call
in a simple web app demo.
So I've been talking, um,
about monitoring social media.
So this is
a very simple web app.
We're gonna make
this source code available,
so don't worry about that.
And inside this simple web app,
uh, in the middle,
you see a text box.
And that piece of text box is--
we are going to type some text.
And when we click
the "Predict" button,
we are going to make
a prediction call
to Prediction API.
We are going to pass the text
inside the text box
over the network
to Prediction API.
When we get a response,
we are going to show the result
on the right
of that "Predict" button
in the blue--you see,
right now, it's "tag" there,
and that's the response
we get from Prediction API.
Uh, before I show you the codes,
I just want to have
a quick of hands--
um, how many of you have written
any web apps before?
Okay, I see a lot of you.
Uh, how many--
how many of you
have, uh, written
any JavaScripts?
Okay, I see pretty much
almost all of you.
For those minority
in this room, don't worry.
Uh, so I'm going to show you
the examples in JavaScript.
But underlying Prediction API,
it's a RESTful service.
So we also provide
Java libraries,
Python libraries,
Ruby libraries.
So don't worry about JavaScript.
Uh, this is just one example.
But Prediction API
can be called
from many,
many current libraries,
because underlying,
it's all HTTP code,
and it can be called
from pretty much every
programming language you want.
So let's bring up the--
the HTML.
And so here, the first step
you need to do
is to include
the JavaScript library,
which also we announced today.
And this JavaScript library--
the way to use it--
just include that.
And you can see highlight here--
it's just one simple HTML
you have to do.
Just add this one line,
and you'll include
the JavaScript library
for a Prediction API.
Now let's look
at the JavaScript.
So you see on the screen,
there's a function
called "predict."
And this function,
this JavaScript function--
it's going to be called
when we click
that "Predict" button.
So I'm going to show you
how easy to use JavaScript
to make a predict call,
uh, in just one single line.
So here, as you see
on the screen,
it looks like four lines,
but it's just one
simple function call.
And if you look
at this function call,
the name of the function
is called prediction.predict.
And you remember,
we see this in APIs for--
the same name there.
And this function
is just one single function
you need to call.
And inside the body
of this--the arguments--
just two--just put
my two ingredients.
First is the name--
again, it's the name
of the historical data
you uploaded to Google storage.
So here, we put io11/my_data.
And the second argument
is the input,
and this input, again,
is the new piece of text
you want to send
to Prediction API
and want to make a prediction
against it.
So here on the screen, you see
we get this piece of text
from a particular HTML element,
but it's easy--very easy
for you to adapt this.
You just grab whatever
on your web app
and put it inside
this "csvInstance" field.
And you can--
you can send this piece of data
to Google Prediction API.
So at the end,
when a response is returned,
we are going to call a callback
called predictionCallback,
as we highlight here,
and this callback is
a basic JavaScript function.
Inside the function,
we just update the web page.
So let's save this file
and see this in action.
So we are gonna save
this JavaScript file,
and we go back to our web app,
and we are going
to reload the page.
So remember, all we do
is just include one line,
and we include
the JavaScript library,
and we add one function call
to make a prediction.
Uh, so let's type something,
um, in the box.
Say, "I gave my mom
a new Nexus S phone
for Mother's Day."
So this is a new piece of text
we get from social media.
And we want--want to--
want Prediction API
to look at it
based on relationship
with our historical data,
and try to predict,
is this about Android,
App Engine, or Chrome?
So let's hit
the "Predict" button.
Ooh, so now it works.
Uh, it's Android.
So--and this Android is--
as you can see on the--
on the input, there is not--
no word like "Android" there.
But if you--
based on your historical--
like if you, um--
if you collect enough examples,
and you--
Prediction API
can try to figure out
why this piece of text
is about Android.
So let's try something else.
Uh, "Where can I find,
say, extensions for educators?"
So I'm a teacher.
I want to find,
uh, Chrome extensions.
Okay, let's send this piece
of text to Prediction API.
Oh, so now you see the update.
It's now--Prediction API thinks,
based on your history,
this is most likely Chrome,
and you return this
as a Chrome, uh--
this belongs
to the category Chrome.
So I want you--
I want you to remember
that all we do is just add
one include source code
in our HTML,
and we'll add just--
add just one function
using JavaScript library.
So I hope every one of you here
can start to think,
how can I make my apps smarter?
How can I make
my web apps smarter?
Because it's very easy to use.
So now you, as developers,
it's, um--you should think
that you have
these tools at your hands,
and it's very easy to use,
and you can start
to make your apps smarter.
And this is not
just about JavaScripts.
It's--we have--
Prediction API
offers different
kinds of libraries,
so it doesn't matter if you
are writing Android apps
or desktop apps.
It doesn't matter if your apps
run in, um, Android
or tablets or TV
or even in Chrome.
It's--it's everything--
once in the cloud,
you can make a prediction call
over the network.
You can use Prediction API.
Um, with that, I'm very happy
to have, uh,
Ryan and Johannes
from Ford research
to tell you how they can use
machine learning
and Prediction API
to make cars smarter.
[applause]
McGee: So as they mentioned,
uh, I'm with Ford research,
and we're using
the Prediction API
to do some interesting things
with our vehicles.
So Ford's been connecting
drivers with their vehicles
for some time now
using our SYNC system.
And the next step, which we're
gonna talk about today,
is to connect the vehicle
to the cloud,
and we think
that's gonna open up
all sorts of
interesting possibilities.
The cloud's gonna give us access
to real-time data,
such as traffic and weather.
It allows us to leverage
large-scale
computational capabilities.
And if we take that
and couple it
with some intelligent
machine learning,
what we can do is really develop
personalized control systems
that are gonna be optimized
for your individual
driving habits.
The application
that we're talking about today
is a plug-in hybrid.
Now a plug-in hybrid
is an extension
of a normal hybrid vehicle
with two key differences.
First, it has
a much bigger battery,
and secondly,
you can recharge that battery
using the electric grid system.
Now you need to imagine a future
where there are
some geographical areas
that have been defined.
Maybe it's your neighborhood.
Maybe it's near a school,
and maybe it's a government
that's defined this area.
In fact, there was an article
in "The New York Times"
earlier this week
about the French government
looking at this for some
of their biggest cities.
And the idea is that this area--
you want to limit your engine.
You want to try to drive
as an electric vehicle
in those areas.
So our job is to save energy,
so that when you get there,
you can operate that vehicle
as an electric vehicle.
So let's talk about a use case.
I go down to my car.
It's Tuesday, time to go home.
Car says,
"Good afternoon, Ryan.
Are you headed home?"
And I say, "Yes, I am."
It says, "I noticed
there's an EV driving zone
along your route. Would you like
to save some energy for it?"
And I say,
"Yes, that would be great."
So how are we gonna do this?
Well, as you can guess,
we're gonna try to make use
of this Prediction API.
And what we do
is we have driving history.
So this is the personal data
about how you use your car.
Then using that, Prediction API
is gonna build a model,
and we're gonna ask
that API a question.
We're gonna say, "Where's
this driver gonna go to next?"
And then once we know that,
we can optimize the powertrain
for that specific route.
So now I'm gonna turn it over
to my colleague Johannes,
who's gonna take a look
under the hood
and try to explain
exactly how we're doing this.
Yeah, we were gonna use that.
Kristinsson: So before we can
make any prediction,
we need to have data
to predict on.
And since we are gonna predict
where you will be going,
we need to know
where you've been.
And to get that data,
we've asked a few
of our colleagues
to install data loggers
on their vehicles.
Data loggers record
the vehicle's position--
GPS positions, date, time,
and other important
vehicle parameters for us.
Once we've collected that data,
we analyze it
to identify the locations
for each trip--
the origin, the destination,
the time the trip started,
and the date.
We then reformat this
into a format
that's suitable for prediction.
That means that we take
the locations
and convert them to tags,
and we take date and time
and make them scalar variables.
We then upload everything
to the cloud,
just as was shown for us.
This is our, um,
prediction research platform.
It contains
the same functionality
as we have
in our prototype cars,
but allows us to see what's
going on behind the scenes.
The first time--
first thing that happens
is that the vehicle receives
a GPS position,
and since GPS reception
in here is pretty bad,
I will manually inject
a position
that corresponds
to my own home.
Um, say it's it's 6:45
in the morning,
when I'm normally
heading to work.
The application will take
this information,
identify that this belongs
to a location for me--home.
And since the GPS
also contains, uh,
information about date and time,
we have everything we need
in order to make a prediction.
We ask the Google Prediction API
for a categorization request,
namely to reach the location tag
that this input data belongs to.
And as shown here,
it detects that I'm going
to Ryan in the morning,
which is pretty true,
since I'm carpooling with him.
Knowing where we are,
knowing where we're going,
we can also calculate the route.
And we cross-reference that
with a list of our EV zones
in order to create
an optimized strategy
for how to drive this route
as Ryan just told us.
Now everybody's
not 100% predictable.
It's great that you predict
where you're going,
but there might be alternatives.
For example,
this application now believes
that days when I'm not
carpooling with Ryan,
I might be working from home
or from somewhere else.
And, um, just as that,
I can get an optimized strategy
for that route.
This is a research platform,
so I can also change
my input variables.
Say that I want to see
what I'm doing
on--on a Sunday morning
at 10:30.
And a new question is generated
to the Google Prediction API,
and directly,
I get an answer back
and can act on that.
McGee: Thanks, Johannes.
Um, this isn't vaporware.
This is actually Johannes and I
driving the vehicle--
uh, prototype vehicle
just last week
around the Ford campus,
uh, proving out this technology.
So where do we want to go next?
Well, our own driving habits
change over time,
so it's important
that these models
that we're having to predict
future behavior
are gonna change over time.
So that's one element
we want to work on.
And then secondly,
this EV driving zone
is just one example about how
we could use this technology.
But we have a whole list
of other ideas
that we're pursuing, also.
And then taking it back
to the big picture,
really, what we want to do
is use the cloud
to empower the car,
to make it smarter.
And the intersection
of connectivity
and powertrain electrification
I think is really ripe
for innovation.
And the Prediction API
is just one step
to really unlock
that technology.
Now I'd like to turn it
back over to the Google team.
[applause]
Kaplow: Hi, everybody.
I'm Robert Kaplow.
I'm a software engineer
with the Google Prediction API,
and I'm really happy
to be here today
to talk to you guys
about some of the cool stuff
we've been working on.
I want to thank Ryan
and Johannes from Ford research
who are here showing you guys
some of the cool uses
they've been making
with the Prediction API.
And hopefully, you know,
looking at this kind of stuff,
you guys can get some ideas for
some of the really cool things
you guys can do
in your own applications.
Um, so Max has been
talking to you
about the current paradigm
for the Google Prediction API.
You gather a bunch of data
from your users.
Um, you put them
into Google storage.
Store them on the--
on the cloud.
Um, you train a model,
and then you make
predictions on it.
And for a lot of people,
this is great.
You actually have this
big batch of data up front,
which you want to make
predictions on continuously.
But a lot of people
have been asking,
um, what happens if my data's
changing over time?
I'm constantly getting
new data in.
And, you know,
right now, what you have to do
is actually put the--
take the new data,
put it in
comma-separated value format
with the old training sets,
and retrain.
And then you can take, uh,
newer, fresher predictions.
Um, but a lot of people
get data in real time.
They're running their
applications on the web,
on mobile devices,
and users are buying products
and clicking on links.
And your application
is getting tons of data
just flowing in.
And what you'd really like is
a way to have a predictive model
that's actually gonna respond
in real time
as, uh, as your users
are changing and as--
I know--as your data
is changing.
And so today, we're really happy
to announce, uh,
we're launching a new feature
called "Streaming Training."
Um, and this is going
to allow you
to add real-time data
to your predictive model.
So, um, this is
a new API feature.
It's implemented
as a RESTful HTTP call.
And the best way to think
about this is
it's an update
to your predictive model.
So you're not retraining
from scratch.
You're taking your current
predictive model,
adding a new batch of data,
and then it's gonna be,
you know, updated.
So there's a few--
you can imagine,
there's a few advantages
of using this.
First off, it's gonna
quickly adapt to new data.
So say, um, you're doing, um,
categorization of hashtags
of the conference,
so, like App Engine or Chrome.
And all of a sudden, people
are doing hashtags of a new--
a new track, and you really
want to be, like, "okay,
I want to be able to categorize
this very quickly, too,"
and, you know,
using streaming training,
you actually are able to
categorize this new information
without having to manually
update your model.
A second reason
you may want to use this
is it'll automatically improve
performance over time.
In machine learning, the more
data you have, the better.
The more data there is,
the better reflection
it is upon the real world.
Uh, if your data's sparse,
or it's missing pieces,
it won't necessarily do as well.
So even if the underlying
world doesn't change,
and even if there's
no new categories,
and there isn't much change
in the underlying thing
you're trying to track
with your predictive model,
if you're just adding more data,
as it comes in,
as quickly as possible,
this is gonna make your model
as fresh as possible,
and let you apply
the freshest predictions.
Um, so this isn't really, uh,
we'd like you to think about
this as an alternative way
to train predictive models.
We're not deprecating,
uh, training.
In a lot of cases, you actually
may have a fixed amount of data
up front, which you can train
and do predictions on,
and that's great--
if that works for you,
then we definitely recommend it.
But if you have the use case,
we're actually getting
a lot of data in real time,
you know, in an application,
in a web app, in a mobile app,
in a desktop app, um,
and it's constantly
coming to you,
I would really recommend you try
using streaming training.
So let's look a little bit more
how, uh, streaming training
is actually implemented
in the Google prediction API.
So we're calling this
"Step 4: Adapt,"
and this will stream new data
to your predictive model.
So this is actually implemented
as a put call in HTTP.
Um, the path is similar
to what we've seen before.
It's training/, uh,
the name of the model
that you want to update
with the streaming training.
And so there's a couple pieces
of information
you have to put into the body.
Uh, think of this as a piece of
the common separate value format
you did at the beginning.
The first piece
is the class label.
For example, we're doing,
uh, you know, #youtube.
This is a new piece of data
someone's posted with #youtube.
This is the true label
of the data.
This is what you're
trying to say,
"Okay, this is what the data
should look like."
In future predictions,
this is the kind of--
the class label that's
associated with this.
So this is really like one line
in the original training set.
So you'd want to make this, uh,
this update,
um, every time you get
a new piece of true data.
The second piece is the common
separate value instance.
This is the features
of the new piece of data.
In this case,
it's a single text feature.
Uh, I just saw this
wicked cool video.
So somebody made a, um,
a social media post with this,
with #youtube,
and so since it's marked
as #youtube,
we actually know
this is a real piece of data.
So we're gonna use this
to update our predictive model.
And when we do enough data
like this,
when people start posting stuff,
you know, about YouTube,
but it's not necessarily
tagged as YouTube,
we'll be able to predict this--
okay, this actually should be
categorized under the YouTube.
And then after that, we see,
uh, the response from the HTTP.
So let's look at how we can use,
uh, streaming training
in our content tagger
application.
So, um,
first, we're going to--
so this is the "Adapt" part
of the application.
Uh, as before,
you have text inputs,
which we're trying
to make a prediction off,
and we're gonna
have a new function there
called "Learn New Hashtag."
So first, let's, uh,
put a piece of text.
Um, this channel's video
has a lot of hits.
And so keep in mind, this is
with our old predictor model.
We actually haven't
done any updating yet.
This is with the predictive
model we trained,
uh, just before.
So let's see what we get.
So, uh, we get #android.
This actually has very little
to do with Android,
but remember,
the only tags we have so far
are Android, Chrome,
and App Engine.
So this looks as much like
Android as anything else.
The predictor model
really has no way
of knowing this is YouTube.
We never even told it
YouTube exists.
So let's see how we can modify
your application
to quickly adapt
to new, uh, data,
and this will allow us
to get better predictions.
So we have, uh, a function,
"Send Update,"
which takes in a text snippet.
This is gonna send, uh--
we want this to send an update
to the prediction API
to make an update call with
a new piece of, uh, text input.
And so, um,
we're gonna use
the JavaScript library,
uh, and the function call
is called, uh,
prediction.training.update.
And so let's look at this
a little bit more closely.
You'll notice this
resembles a lot like
the underlying HTTP request,
um, and in any
client library you use,
it's gonna look
something like this.
This is the JavaScript library,
but as Max mentioned,
we have a lot of client
libraries already available.
Um, so the first piece is
the, uh, the name of the data,
uh, the predictive model
that you want to update.
So we're still using
the same model
that I just trained before,
io11/my_data.
Then the next piece,
the class label--
this is where we're seeing
the true label is,
um,, so we're gonna grab that
from the topic field.
This is the piece
on the, uh, HTML form
we're gonna fill in ourselves.
And finally, the common
separate value of instance,
and we're just putting in
that text snippet,
which is the input
to the function.
And finally, we--we execute
an update callback.
So, uh, let's save.
We're modifying our application.
Um, and let's go back
to the content tagger demo
and, uh, see what happens.
So we want to learn
a new hashtag
based on a whole
bunch of new data,
so we've actually, uh, written
a whole bunch of comments
that look like YouTube comments.
Uh, we're gonna put #youtube,
and then update.
So we're gonna quickly skim
through the comments.
This is--we're just putting
a whole bunch of data
into the system.
So for us, it was
a little bit trickier--
we actually wanted to put
it all up in ahead of time,
but--and so we actually
did a little bit of work
to actually list through them
and do an update for each one.
For your application,
it's actually much simpler.
As soon as the data is created,
as soon as the user's clicked
on the link or bought the item,
you say, "Okay,
this is a real prediction,"
and you can just
put that together,
put the--you know,
put it into a JSON,
and call your client library,
and away it'll go.
Um, so we've updated our--
our, uh, predictive model
using this new hashtag,
so let's try the same, um,
string again.
Uh, this channel's video
has a lot of hits.
So we're going to, uh,
run prediction,
and before, we got #android.
Um, did you update?
Oh, you have to refresh
the page, I think.
So, uh, we didn't actually
refresh the page,
um, and so notice,
he actually live-coded this,
so we're gonna try this again.
Okay, so as I said,
we've done an update,
so we've gone through all
these pieces of new text,
and, um, now that all the text
has been--
so each piece gets sent
to the prediction API,
and we say,
"This is a new instance,"
and we're really updating
our predictive model.
So let's try again
on the text string.
Great.
So we've, uh, got--
[applause]
Kaplow: So we've predicted,
uh, the new hashtag, #youtube.
Remember, the predictive model,
before we did this update,
didn't even know
what YouTube was,
so we can actually
add new class labels
as you're updating your model.
And that's not the only reason
you would want to do this.
Even if there's no new
class labels, as I've mentioned,
um, you can just keep
on putting more data,
and the model's just gonna
learn more and more
about the world,
and it's just gonna improve.
It'll, you know,
work better for more users.
It's just gonna get
better over time.
Um, so you can see how
you can use this
to improve your application.
I just want to give
a couple of comments
on how you may want to use, uh,
streaming training
in your application.
Uh, first of all, um,
when you're adding new data,
you really should add
all the data that, um,
represents the world,
so you shouldn't actually
just be putting one piece
in your data, like, one
new class label, or whatever.
You really want to be throwing
all the data,
as much as possible, um,
together, so don't just say,
"I want to learn this
new type of information,"
because that could
really bias the model.
The models' gonna
start thinking,
oh, okay, this is what
it looks like now.
So you really want to have
as good of representation
as possible, and that actually
makes your life easier,
'cause you really just
want to naively just send--
you know, put the information
in there.
And a second, uh,
bit of information
about when you're using
streaming training is, um,
the predictive model
isn't only--
isn't going to work with a very,
very small amount of data.
Especially, the larger
your model is, um,
you need more and more
information for it to learn.
So don't just, you know,
send a couple instances,
and expect it's gonna work,
you know, magically,
you know, over, across
all YouTube comments.
If you want it to recognize
YouTube really well,
you have to give
a lot of comments.
So really give as much
comments as you can--
or, as much input as you can
across all the type--
different types of data,
and, uh, streaming training's
gonna work much better.
Uh, and with that,
I'm gonna turn it over to Max,
who's gonna talk about another
really exciting new feature,
um, we're talking about today.
Thanks a lot.
[applause]
Lin: So I hope that
you are all excited
about this new feature
we just announced,
the streaming training.
It makes your life much easier
to adapt whatever the users--
a user can change,
data can change,
but this really make it easier
to incorporate predictions
and make your app smarter.
Uh, before I tell you
another new feature,
I want to get,
have a quick of hands, like,
how many of you are already
in our Beta group,
and have used Prediction API?
Okay, some of you.
Um, I'd like to take this chance
and really thank you
for using Prediction API.
Beta users, we get a lot
of good feedback from you guys,
and--and we--
one of the feedback is, uh,
they want to make apps smarter,
and also faster.
So Prediction API
is easy to use,
just simple three steps.
It sounds easy.
But say I'm a--I'm a--
I'm an ice cream
e-commerce web site.
I know how to sell
ice cream sandwiches.
I know people--
when they buy vanilla,
they also like chocolate.
I can learn this,
use Prediction API.
But I know nothing
about sentiment.
Uh, but what if I want--
when people talk about my
ice cream sandwich web site,
I want to know,
are they excited or not,
are they happy or not?
So how can I incorporate
this in our e-commerce web site,
or my social media monitoring?
So today, we are very happy
to announce a new feature
in Prediction API
called
Hosted Model Subscriptions.
And the idea is that
at Google Prediction API,
we are going to host
a bunch of different models,
and those models--
those predictive models
are pretrained,
and you just subscribe to them,
and you can use.
So that's why the name
is "Hosted Models,"
and you subscribe
to the hosted models.
So what that means to you--
so let's go back
to the ice cream sandwich
e-commerce web site.
So you don't have expertise,
you don't know how to do
sentiment analysis--that's fine.
But there are a lot of people
who are experts
in analyze piece of text,
they already collect the data,
so why can't you just
stand on their shoulders
and leverage their efforts?
So if there is a hosted model
about sentiment analysis
you can right now subscribe to,
it's much, much easier for you.
Right now, you can just
add that functionality
in your web apps
or Android apps,
and make your apps--
can do sentiment analysis.
So that's--we really want
to offer this feature
to make your apps smarter
and faster just right now.
So the--
so there are several, uh,
the reason we wanted to do this.
So first, we want to build this
Hosted Model subscription,
uh, it's mostly of developers.
It's--today, we are going
to give you
some examples of hosted models,
but really, we want to hope
this is a marketplace
for developers.
Uh, that's--the model's--
the hosted model should provide
and develop by the developers.
And also, what we really want
these hosted models--
um, it's driven by
the developers' needs.
So if you--
if you develop some apps,
and you're really looking
for some hosted models,
some pretrained model
for your needs,
say, for example,
I really want a good spam
detector that can filter out
all the inappropriate content
on my forum,
so I really want a detector
that can do that.
So really want--
if you have those needs,
would you let us know--
there's a sign-off form
on our document web site,
and you can tell us, "I really
want this hosting model."
On the other hand,
if you have a hosted model
you developed for yourself,
say, you already
have a very good, uh,
spam detectors, working very
well for yourself, and you--
now this is a chance for you
to share with other developers,
and you can also monetize
on these hosting models,
on the models you develop
using Prediction API.
So as you can see, there's a--
this should be a marketplace
for people looking for models
and for people to want
to sell their models.
And the third point is,
the whole reason
we want to do this
is for the developers.
We really want to--
want to make your apps smarter,
but we also want
to make it very easy.
Right now, you don't have
to collect training data.
You can stand
on other people's shoulder.
They already do
the heavy liftings,
why can't you just
stand on their shoulders
and use hosting models?
and you can start to use, um,
you can make a prediction
right now in your apps.
So I'm going to show you, uh--
let's go back to
our web app examples.
Uh--oh, before I do that,
I forgot to tell you the syntax.
Uh, the syntax, again,
is very simple HTTP call,
and the syntax similar
to the prediction call
we just introduced before.
Uh, the only difference that--
uh, instead of saying training,
here, the syntax
is prediction/v1.2.
That's the version number,
and /hostedmodels,
so instead of saying training,
you specify, hey,
I want to make a prediction
against a particular
hosted model,
and you just append the
hosted model name after that,
and at the end,
you append predict.
That means you want
to make a prediction
against a particular
hosted model.
Inside the body,
it's just the same as before.
When you make a prediction,
you just pass, uh,
a new data point,
a new piece of text,
and you send over
to Prediction API,
and Prediction API
will take your input,
uh, look up the hosted models
you specify,
and give you a response.
So you--as you can see,
there's no training
and, uh, collection data phase.
You can just right now
make a prediction
against a hosting model.
So I'm going to show you, uh,
how we can incorporate
hosted model
in our web app demo.
So remember, we collect a bunch
of data on a social media
and try to detect when people
talk about App Engine,
Android, or Chrome,
but I know nothing
about sentiment.
I really want to know when
people talk about App Engine,
or Chrome,
uh, are they excited,
uh, or not?
So I really want to, uh,
do a sentiment analysis.
So when I--
uh, as you can see
in the middle of the box,
uh, I--when I type
something there,
I really want to send
to Prediction API.
Uh, first, I want to know
what category, uh,
this piece of text is about,
but I also want to know,
is this piece of text
expressing any positive
or negative sentiment?
So how can we do that?
Let's, uh, go back
to our JavaScript,
uh, examples.
Uh, again, I want to emphasize,
this is not just--not just
working for JavaScripts.
We have Java, Python, Ruby,
and various libraries
for you to use.
Um, so here, uh,
again, it's a very simple,
one function call
you have to make.
Uh, it looks like four lines,
but it's just one function call,
and the name
of the function call
is called
prediction.hostedmodels.predict.
So inside this function call,
you just pass two arguments.
First, obviously,
is the name of the hosted model
you want to make
a prediction against,
so here, we want to do
a sentiment analysis,
and today, we provide
a simple example
called simple.sentiment.
So the name--
this simple.sentiment
is a hosted model,
hosted right now at
Prediction API for you to use.
You don't have to collect data,
you can right now make
a prediction against it.
And the second piece of argument
is the input field
in the JSON format,
and that's basically the input
you want to send
to Prediction API,
a piece of text you want
to detect a sentiment.
So again, inside this predict
function, JavaScript function,
you see we make two calls--
one is the one we make
against our own
historical data,
the second one
is the prediction call,
but it's against
a particular hosted model,
um,
and we want to get a sentiment.
And, uh, save it, and, uh,
go back to our web app
and reload,
and see how it works.
So this is the "Subscribe" phase
of our web, uh, demo,
so we are going to type a piece
of text inside this box.
Say, uh, "I gave my mom
a new Nexus S phone,
and she really liked it."
And let's press the "Predict."
And it works.
So on the right
of the "Predict" button,
first, you see there
is an Android,
and that's come from
our own historical data
we collect ourself,
and you also see another
response from Prediction API.
It's positive,
and that's the response--
the category return
by Prediction API
against the hosted models
that we don't have
to collect data,
but we can, right now,
very easily incorporate this
in our web app
with just one function call.
You don't have to collect data,
and you can use right away.
Um, let's just try
something else.
Um, um, say,
"I really don't like
this music video."
So suppose you get
this piece of text
from social media,
and you want to know,
what is this about,
and are people excited or not?
And it works, again.
Um, so the tag you see here
is YouTube,
and remember, the reason
we can get YouTube
is because Robert
just showed you,
we adapt to
the new piece of data.
Before, we know
nothing about Android
in the beginning
of this demo.
Now we learn this is about--
probably related to YouTube.
And we also get a response
from hosted models,
and this is negative,
somehow expressing
a negative sentiment
uh, and the hosted model
detect this in a hosted model.
Um,
so I hope by this point, uh,
you all feel very excited,
and start to think,
how I can incorporate
hosted models--in your apps.
If there's any hosting models
you really want,
please let us know.
If you have hosted models
you really want to share
with other developers,
please also let us know.
With that, I'm gonna
hand back to, uh, Travis.
[applause]
Green: So some of you may
actually have models
that are built outside
of the prediction API,
and we have one final thing
that we want to announce,
which is that we're also
starting to support
an open standard,
called the Predictive Model
Markup Language,
which enables you to import
predictive models from elsewhere
and then bring them
into the API,
either to share with others,
or for your own use.
So you can see onscreen
how all this works.
You bring in your model, uh,
via the PMML mark--
PMML syntax,
and then we will make it
available to you.
So that's the end
of our announcements,
but I just want to get
you guys thinking about
some other ways
you can use this system.
So I know we talked you through
a sentiment analysis example.
Um, you can also imagine,
as we've also
been talking about,
having an e-commerce site,
and as people buy things,
building a large
recommendation engine
to show them other things
they might be interested in.
You can also imagine filtering
inappropriate content,
sexual content,
other sorts of, um,
things that you don't
want on your site.
Whether users are gonna stay
with your site or leave it--
churn prediction.
Uh, the examples go on and on,
so you can see 15 here,
but there are many,
many, many more.
Um, and I also just
want to close
by telling you
what we've told you,
which is that we've made it
so anyone can access the API.
We've shown you how you can make
even fresher models
through the streaming updates
that Rob showed you.
We've shown you that
you can just drop in
really expert predictive models
using our forthcoming gallery,
and you can try
all these things today.
So we look forward to both
your questions,
and to seeing the applications
you build with the API.
Thank you all so much.
We have--thank you.
[applause]
Green: We have microphones
on both sides of the room.
Uh, please speak into them
to ask a question,
so that the people
on the video can hear you,
and everyone across the room
can hear you.
Um, I'll take one
from there first,
'cause you were
the first one up.
man: Okay, um, this is awesome.
Green: Great.
man: I was there at the talk,
you know, last year,
and I was trying
to figure out how to do it.
A couple of questions--
Green: Sure.
man: One is that, do you have--
uh, can you,
or have you used this
for ADT extraction--
for example, if I take--
let me give you an example.
Green: Mm-hmm.
man: If I go into,
um, TechCrunch,
I feed all the--
take analysis feed,
feed all the articles--
that's my learning data...
Green: Mm-hmm.
man: Then I take
the crunch base,
and take all the list of
companies that are represented
and products that are there,
and then that is my--
you know,
the identification
of what this learning data
is about.
Now I throw in a new article...
Green: Mm-hmm.
man: Let's say from
"New York Times,"
or from "Ink" magazine,
or something like that,
can it come back and give me
a list of companies
from this article?
[speaking indistinctly]
Green: So--yeah, sorry.
Yeah, so the way you would
structure that sort of problem
would be you would take
the TechCrunch text,
and have the output,
the prediction you're making,
in the training set
be the actual companies
contained within that article.
We can talk more about
how exactly that goes through,
but that's conceptually
how it would work.
man: Okay, and similar things
can be done for products...
Green: Yes, yes.
man: And technologies and events
and stuff like that.
Green: Yeah, we'll be here
all at the end,
and I'm happy to talk you
through that all in detail,
if you don't mind.
man: That's great.
Green: Great, awesome.
man: So this changes search
quite a bit, right, you know,
there is the interesting
implications on search for this.
Green: It changes
a lot of things,
so we look forward to seeing
what you guys can build.
I'll take the question
here next,
and bounce back and forth
from there.
man: So, uh, will there be,
like, complex data types,
or, like, video
or sound or music?
Green: [laughs]
You guys want so much.
[laughs]
Um, we're working on it.
Um, it would be great to hear
how exactly you want to use it,
so that we know which ones
to prioritize first,
um, yeah, so let's
talk at the end,
and we can talk through how
exactly you want to use it,
if you don't mind.
man: Okay, thanks.
Green: Great, thanks.
Over there.
man: Uh, yes, is there, like,
a feedback mechanism,
so you show, like,
a list of, uh, results--
well, actually don't show
a list of results--
but you show if it's positive,
negative, or you show a tag--
what if the user
feels it's wrong?
Green: Yes.
man: Does it go back
to the system?
Green: So a few things--
we actually do show
a distribution across
all possible categories,
so we didn't show that here,
because, uh,
you actually have to look
at the syntax of the JSON,
it's sometimes hard to parse.
We actually show distribution,
so if you have three categories,
"A," "B," and "C,"
there is, you know,
"A" is .5, "B" is .3,
"C" is .2,
that sort of thing.
Um, and you had a second part
to your question
I blanked on, I'm sorry.
man: Yeah, if the user doesn't
think your prediction is right,
does it go back
to the system?
Green: Yes. So that's why we--
one of the many reasons
why we enabled
streaming updates, uh,
is so that you can then do that
and say, "Hey, this was wrong."
You know, we tagged
this piece of comment--
or this comment improperly,
um, please retag it
in this training set
as being something else,
so you--what you can do,
is you can take what the user
has told you as being a label,
and reapply it
through the update
into the predictive model.
man: Oh, okay.
Green: Yeah.
man: Also, another question...
Green: Sure.
man: So the examples
you have shown
kind of just show
classification, I guess...
Green: Yes.
man: But, uh, is there,
like, prediction
on the, like--uh, yeah, I guess
Max kind of mentioned it--
a continuous value...
Green: Yes, yes, there is.
Yeah, it's all documented
on the web site.
Feel free to look there.
It's--yeah.
man: Okay. Okay, thank you.
Green: Great. Oh, no worries.
I think we have time
for one more question.
Again, as I said, we'll
actually be up here,
so please come up
and ask them. Yes, sir?
man: I was gonna ask
the same question,
but I rephrased it
a little bit.
Green: Sure.
man: If a user thinks
it's wrong,
or he may think it's right...
Green: Mm-hmm.
man: Can the system learn?
'Cause retagging
is a little different.
Can the current tagging
be marked as saying
you guys--you didn't do a good
job, it's wrong--or it's right?
Green: Yeah, so the system
runs on, um--
well, I'll refer you
to the engineering team,
so you can get a specific answer
as to how it works,
but basically, there's no way
currently to provide through
that negative reinforcement
you're talking about.
man: Like supervised learning,
that's what I'm talking about.
Green: Yeah,
we're primarily focused.
on positive reinforcement.
man: Okay, okay, okay, I see.
Green: Great.
man: And second question,
it's great that you allow,
uh, to import our current model
into yours...
Green: Yes.
man: Would you allow
to export?
Green: So we use, um,
both publicly available
and proprietary models, so we
don't currently support export.
Um, if you do want
to export your model,
we can talk about that.
That's something we've talked
about internally.
But we'll have to be sure to
pull out the proprietary ones.
man: All right, thanks.
Green: Oh, no worries.
Um, thank you all so much.
Um, those of you
who are still here,
we would be happy to answer your
questions up here at the end.
Um, thank you again for coming.
[applause]